in this.net 6 course amikai will teach
you how to build a rest api amikai is a
software engineer at microsoft and he is
great at breaking down complex technical
topics in a way that's easy for
beginners to understand hi everyone
today we're going to be building a crud
based rest api completely from scratch
i'm really excited to be collaborating
with free code camp on this video so i
really hope you're going to like it and
i can't wait to hear what you think okay
so what are we building today well today
we're going to be building the back end
for the fictional application uber
breakfast kind of what is this breakfast
application well it's basically a system
in which you can create breakfast
and as you can see every breakfast has a
title a description a star and end time
some savory items over here and also
some sweet items and because what we're
building is a crud based rest api then
as you would expect the actions that we
can do
are creating a new breakfast reading
breakfasts
updating a breakfast and also let's
imagine that somewhere in our system we
have the option to delete a breakfast as
well okay so if this sounds intriguing
make sure to watch until the end because
by the end of this video you should have
a good understanding of all the topics
that we're going to be covering
okay moving on to the architecture of
the project so as you can see by the end
of this video we're going to have two
projects now you don't need to remember
what this looks like but what i do want
you to notice is that we have two
projects one containing the definition
of our api so this models our api
definition and another one with the
actual logic of our application okay
moving on to the technologies that we're
going to use
so we're going to be using dot net 6 and
we're going to use the dot net cli and
visual studio code for everything else
as part of this video then you will get
familiar with some new.net cli commands
and some pretty cool visual studio code
extensions which hopefully you'll be
able to take and add to your toolkit
okay moving on to the architecture
choices so as we said we're building a
crud rest api this means a system in
which you can create read update and
delete resources so not every back-end
system needs to follow clean
architecture and domain-driven design
principles especially when the
application is small or medium it can
add a few layers of complexity which
aren't always worth the effort so today
we're going to be building something
that is suitable for small to medium
sized applications and hopefully you'll
be able to take what we're going to be
building today and use it in your
applications even if yours is completely
different okay now even though we're
creating a quote simple application we
want to make sure that our application
is resilient and it will scale well as
our application has more and more
features and more error flows that's why
we're going to incorporate some
interesting concepts from functional
programming and also some principles
from domain-driven design which will
make our application more resilient and
better organized okay lastly who am i so
my name is amica i'm a software engineer
at microsoft i love creating all these
visual engineering infographics on the
various social media platforms and i
actually just launched a new youtube
channel a few weeks ago in which we
write a lot of codes we cover design
patterns and architectures that are a
bit more advanced than what we're going
to be seeing today so if you like what
you see today then feel free to follow
me on the various social media platforms
you might enjoy my content
hi everyone i'm mikhail here i do have a
quick disclaimer so i am a microsoft
employee and these are microsoft
technologies but i'm not talking on
behalf of microsoft these are my
personal opinions okay so without
further ado let's start writing some
code so as we said we're going to have
two projects one that models our api
and another one which will contain the
actual logic of our application okay now
if you're asking yourself why would i
want to split my application into two
separate projects while having your api
definition which is a bunch of c-sharp
classes in a separate project allows you
to define it as a class library and then
publish it as a nougat package then if
your client is written in dot net then
they can simply consume this nougat
package instead of remodeling the api
themselves okay now this also works well
with versioning so as your api evolves
and you have new versions then when you
want to publish the v2 of your api then
all you need to do is publish a new
nuget package and all the client needs
to do is simply consume the new package
okay so let's get started the first
thing we want to do is create a new
solution
so let's go ahead and create our blooper
breakfast solution so dot new
sln and let's give it the name uber
breakfast
hey as you would expect this creates the
boober breakfast folder which inside has
the uber breakfast solution
now let's go ahead and create our
projects so dot new class lib and let's
give it a name boober breakfast
dot contracts
right so this is a project that models
our api
great now let's create
our actual web api so dotnet new
web api
and let's give it the name boober
breakfast
okay let's try building the project so
dot net build
and we get a warning that says unable to
find a project to restore now this may
seem a bit weird because we just created
two projects
but when working with the.net cli then
it's not enough to just create the
projects because if we look at the
solution file then we can see it's still
empty and there are actually no projects
defined in it so let's go ahead and add
both of our projects to the solution
file so dot net sln add
and we want to add the boober breakfast
dot contracts
and the booby breakfast project click
okay this adds them okay now you can
actually do this in a shorter way so you
can do dotnet sl and and you can specify
over here all the projects recursively
like so so you can go ahead and choose
whatever is more convenient for you okay
now that we have all of that defined
let's go ahead and open this in visual
studio code
okay so we open the project in visual
studio code and as we expect we have the
solution that we created and the two
projects
if we look at the solution then after we
added the two projects we can see that
they're defined over here
if we look at the two projects then over
here this is just a class library we're
using.net 6 and we have nullable
reference types enabled which basically
means if we haven't defined that an
object can be null then it can't be null
okay let me just close this stuff over
here okay and over here we have the web
api so because we created the project
from the.net cli using the web api
template then we get here a few things
out of the box okay so looking at the cs
proj okay so as we said we're using the
dotnet sdk dot net six and also here we
have nullable reference types enabled
okay now the first thing i want to do is
actually to create your new folder it's
called docs and over here let's create a
file
api.markdown
what i'm going to do is paste here the
definition of the api that we're going
to be building and i'm going to open it
using the markdown preview enhanced
extension if you aren't familiar with
visual studio code then over here you
have a tab in which you can search and
install extensions for visual studio
code so this extension is called
markdown preview enhanced and all you
need to do is select it click install
and then over here
when you right click then you'll have
the option to open it using this
extension
so let me put it over here so it catches
the entire screen and i want to open it
side by side with our client application
okay starting with the c of chrono then
the way you create a breakfast is you
basically call the breakfast endpoint
using the http verb post and as you
would expect what you have over here is
basically a breakfast
right so we have the name which
corresponds to this the description
which corresponds to this the start and
end date time which corresponds to this
over here
then we have a list of savior items
which is this and suite items which is
this the only thing that's missing from
the schema is perhaps a list of images
but let's imagine that we're just
building the mpp and so in a future
iteration we'll add this feature as well
okay if we created a dinner successfully
then we get
the http status code 201 created and the
location header which gives us details
on how to fetch the breakfast that we
just created if we'd like and the
response content contains all the
details that we sent including a server
generated id and another server
generated property a last modified date
time
moving on to the r of card
so we call this endpoint over here and
specify the id of a breakfast that we
want to read and to indicate that we
want to retrieve data then we're going
to use http get if the breakfast exists
then we'll get http status code 200 and
then the response will get the breakfast
that we requested okay moving on to
update breakfast then to update
breakfast you would specify the idea of
the breakfast that you want to update
and use the http verb put and in the
request content you would specify the
new details if the dinner was updated
successfully then we get 204 no content
but if the specified id doesn't exist
then following the rfc specification for
put will return 201 created and the
response will be similar to the response
of creating a resource so even though
this is called update this is actually
upsert so we'll update the resource if
it already exists or it will create a
new resource if it doesn't exist last
but not least we have the delete
breakfast basically you specify the id
of the breakfast that you want to delete
with the http verb delete and if it was
deleted successfully then we'll get 204
no content so by the end of this video
we'll create an api that behaves in the
good flow like what we saw over here but
don't worry we're also going to have
error handling so if something goes
wrong we'll return the appropriate
response to the client
okay so i actually want to open the api
definition again on the right so we have
it visible while we're modeling our api
okay so let's start with create
breakfast so over here in the contract
project let's get rid of this
auto-generated class let's create a new
folder it's called breakfast
and over here let's create a new file
called create breakfast request
and as we defined in our api so this
will be public record
create breakfast request
so this will be string name
spring description yes
daytime
start daytime
yes and daytime
then we have here a list of savory
and a list of sweet items as well
great moving on to the response so
actually the response both of the create
breakfast and the get breakfast are
identical so let's just create a single
file to model both of these responses
let's call it a breakfast response
so breakfast response
and actually let's just copy paste this
entire thing let's add the extra fields
so this over here will be response
we have here a guide
and other than these two daytimes we
also have here a less modified
daytime
right so as we said we already have this
defined over here on the left
now let's create the option request so
absurd
breakfast request
and over here as well just copy paste
this entire thing over here
let's change it from create
to
upsert
and
that's it right
right now that we have the api modeled
in c-sharp classes let's go ahead and
start implementing the actual logic
okay now if you aren't familiar with web
apis and i want you to have something to
imagine as we were writing some of the
code so i want you to imagine that when
the user clicks the create new breakfast
request with a new breakfast that he
just defined
then the following details are sent to
the server to the create dinner endpoint
and you can imagine that the request
arrives over here at the breakfast
controller and we'll be able to extract
the details that were sent and
manipulate them the way we want so in
our case we want to store them in the
database okay then in the response then
whatever the breakfast controller
returns then it'll simply be returned to
the client and then the client can take
the information that was returned
and display it back to the user so back
in our application because we created
the web api using the command line
interface template we get here some
files which we don't care about so let's
go ahead and get rid of everything that
we aren't going to need so we can get
rid of this weather forecast controller
this weather forecast
file
and the program cs let's get rid of
everything we aren't going to use in
this video so we can get rid of this
of this
of all this
and of this as
well okay now if you're used to seeing
both a program cs and a startup cs then
what we have over here is the new
template starting from dot net six where
over here you have the builder variable
which you can use for dependency
injection and configuration and over
here you have your app variable in which
you can manage the request pipeline okay
now a nice trick that i saw is creating
here a scope and putting this inside
like this and
same over here
just makes it seem a bit more organized
okay last thing over here we can now get
rid
of this package reference since we
aren't using it anymore and that's it
okay so
let's start defining our endpoints
so over here let's create our
breakfasts controller
so this will be public class
breakfasts
controller which will inherit from the
controller base this is coming from this
namespace over here
okay we want to add the api controller
attribute
this is an attribute that we get out of
the box with asp.net
and it does some heavy lifting for us
okay so let's start defining our
endpoints so let's start with a create
breakfast request so
http post
and here let's specify the route so yes
breakfast
this will be public i action results
create breakfast
let's see what it's suggesting
yes
you know we can try to add the contract
namespace but it's not recognized that's
because we don't have any reference to
the contracts project so let's go ahead
and add this reference so dotnet add and
then we need to tell which project so in
our case we want the blue breakfast
project to reference
the contracts project
okay this added the reference to the
contracts project so now we should be
able
to add the namespace
great and for now let's just return the
request
next we have our get endpoint so let's
just copy this entire thing and paste it
over here let's change this to http get
over here let's add the
yes the id
and because we want this to be a guide
then we can add here guide and the
framework will enforce that this must be
guided
let's change this to get breakfast
and over here we have our guide
and for now let's simply return here the
guide
next we have our update breakfast
request
so again let's copy
this method over here and
paste it
let's change http post to put
this
will be similar to what we have over
here so let's simply copy and paste it
and let's change this to
observe breakfast
and over here this won't be the create
breakfast request but rather it will be
the absurd
breakfast request and of course we also
want to extract the id from the route so
id okay and lastly we have our delete
endpoint so let's copy
the get endpoint and paste it down here
let's change http get
to http delete
let's change the name
from
get
to delete
and that's it for now
let's close the api definition and make
sure that this works as we expect so
dotnet build
create it build successfully let's go
ahead and run the project so this will
be.net run and here we need to specify
which project so in our case it's the
uber breakfast project let's click enter
this will build and run our application
right now to make requests i want to
introduce another visual studio code
extension
so let's go back to the extensions tab
and look over here for rest client
okay this is the one you'll see it has
two million downloads and a lot of love
from the users simply click install and
you'll be able to run http requests like
we're going to demonstrate now
so the way this looks is let's create
here a new folder let's copy requests
inside here let's create another poll
that's called breakfast
and in here let's create a great
breakfast request
okay so it's simply a file that ends
with dot http okay and the way this
extension works so you basically just
write the request that you want to send
and you can see that just writing the
http verb already pops out this send
request option then you simply click it
and it sends the request for you so
let's open our api definition again on
the right
and create our first request so we want
the host slash
breakfasts
underneath we can define whatever
headers that we want so in our case we
want the content type
application json and below our request
body which is
this thing over here
okay let's try sending the request and
making sure that the endpoint simply
returns the request as we defined so we
sent it and we got it as we expect
great let's go ahead and create our
other requests as well so over here we
have also the get breakfast request
the upsert
breakfast request
and
lastly the delete
breakfast request
okay let's copy the create request to
the upload request because they're very
similar
but instead of post this will be put and
over here will have the id of the
breakfast that we want to update so
let's just take
some id from over here and paste it in
our request okay now something cool that
you can do with this extension is create
variables so you can say for example
that the id is
let's copy the
id over here
and paste it here
and then we can simply replace this
entire thing with id
and you can see that there's even
intellisense so you can autocomplete and
over here you even have navigate to
definition
pretty cool
okay so this is our update endpoint it
corresponds to the definition of our api
over here
let's move on to the get breakfast so
let's simply paste this over here let's
paste the id as well actually
and instead of put this will be get
and the delete will be similar to this
only we'll have here instead of get
delete
let's make sure our definition is
correct so create we already tested
let's make sure that delete works as
well so right over here we just simply
return the id
forget also we return the ib and for
upsert we should be returning the
request
great so now that we have everything
wired together and we have all our
requests defined let's go back
to the controller and think what we want
to do over here so let me just close all
these windows on the right
also let's stop the application you can
do it by clicking ctrl c
okay back in our controller one last
thing that i want to do so because all
our endpoints start with the word
breakfast we can simply go over here and
write real
breakfasts
and then we can remove
this
this
this
and
this as well
and because it's very common to have the
route
simply the name of the class without the
word controller then the framework also
allows us to do something like this
where you simply write controller and
then all the endpoints will be prefixed
by the name of the class without the
word controller
okay so now let's think what we want to
do so let's start with the create
breakfast endpoint so as we said we have
here the request now we don't want to
store the request as it is in the
database for a couple of reasons one it
doesn't have all the properties that we
want so for example the id property
doesn't exist and the last modified
property doesn't exist but also because
we want the flexibility to be able to
change things inside our system without
having to change the contract that we
have with our clients okay so what we
want to do over here is take the request
that we received
converted to the internal service model
and inside our application will only
speak in the language of these models
and not the language of the contracts
then tomorrow morning we can create a
new api version and all we need to do is
convert the new api definition to our
internal service language and then we
can support multiple versions and our
system is more flexible so
for that let's create our internal
breakfast representation so let's go
ahead and create here a new folder it's
called
and in here let's create our breakfast
object
okay so this will be public class
breakfast
and over here let's have
yes actually this seems right but
because we want to make sure that this
is always built with valid values and we
don't want to give anyone holding the
object the option to simply set new
values to our properties then let's get
rid of all the sets over here
and let's create a constructor
great let's just wrap the line here so
it's visible
okay and now not only that no one can
change the id for example after it was
set but also over here
we can enforce
whatever logic that we want so if we
have some logic for example that the
name of the description can be shorter
than three characters then we can
enforce it over here and then once it's
created we know this value is always
valid in whatever valid means inside our
system
okay so back
in the controller
let's map the request to this breakfast
object so let's say over here breakfast
equals and here let's say
yes this thing's about right
let's make sure that we have here
everything that we need
right so we take all the values and we
generate a new id and for the last
modified we simply pass utc now okay the
next thing we want to do
is is somehow yes saved to the database
then we want to take the breakfast that
we created and
map it to our breakfast response
and from here we want to return
our response
okay now this over here will return 200
okay right because we're using the base
method okay but what we actually want to
return is 201 created so let's go ahead
and use the created apps and as you can
see there are a few options over here
we're going to use this one over here
but there are other options okay now
this method receives three things
first of all it receives the action in
which the client can retrieve the
resource so in our case it's
the get breakfast endpoint
then because the get breakfast endpoint
has a parameter called id then we need
to pass over here an object that has the
id property
so something like this
yes
and lastly the response content
let's just add the argument names though
it's a bit more readable
okay so what we have at the moment is
very common to see in controllers the
first step is mapping the data that we
get in the request to the language that
our application speaks the last step is
taking the data from our system and
converting it back to the api definition
and returning the appropriate response
and over here we have the actual logic
of our application which we're going to
implement now okay so let me just remove
these redundant parentheses over here
and back in our boober brackets folder
let's create a new folder scott services
and over here let's create another
folder called breakfasts and over here
let's create the i breakfast service and
what we'll have over here is the public
interface
yes i breakfast service
let's leave only the create and again we
only want to work with our internal
models so over here we want our
breakfast model and the response let's
have this void for now
and let's change the name of this to
breakfast
great now back in our controller
let's use this interface so private
read-only
yes
let's include the namespace and inject
this
to the constructor
okay if you aren't familiar with
dependency injection then we'll look
into it in a few minutes now down here
let's use it to actually create our
breakfast so
breakfast service create breakfast and
let's pass it to breakfast
okay now let's go ahead and implement
this breakfast service let's create here
a new file let's call it breakfast
service
and over here let's have our public
class
practice service
the ibreakfast service interface
let's go ahead and implement the
interface
okay now as part of this video all we'll
do is just store it in memory but over
here what you would actually do
is use some repository or entity
framework to store it in the database
okay so what we'll have over here is
private read-only dictionary
where we'll map an id to a breakfast
let's just initialize it
then over here all we need to do is
breakfast
dot add
and the idea of the breakfast is the key
and the value is the actual breakfast
great let's just add a new line over
here and back in our controller
for us to be able to test this
end-to-end and see that this actually
works so in the get breakfast
let's try to retrieve the breakfast with
a given id
so yes something like this
let's generate this method
right so this generated the get
breakfast method
which we'll implement over here
so implement the interface and all we
need to do
is simply return
the breakfast that corresponds to the id
that we just received
okay now that we have this method
implemented back in our controller let's
map our breakfast to the breakfast
response so
yes
and let's return the response from here
okay let's run the project
and make the create breakfast request
and see what happens
okay now some of you might have expected
this failure
so the failure we're getting is that the
framework doesn't know what to do when
someone requests the i breakfast service
interface right so back in the
controller we're trying to use the i
breakfast service interface okay now
what actually happens behind the scenes
is that every time we send a request to
the service the framework creates a new
breakfast controller object when it
creates the new breakfast controller
object it also tries to create a new i
breakfast service object and the
framework doesn't know how to
instantiate the interface that the
breakfast controller is requesting so to
fix that let's go to the program cs and
over here define how to create the eye
breakfast service interface so builder
dot services dot add singleton
yes breakfast service okay what we're
telling the framework is that every time
it instantiates an object that object
requests the eye breakfast service in
the constructor then use the breakfast
service object as the implementation of
this interface
and over here we have a few options for
the lifetime of this breakfast service
object
so specifying here singleton tells the
framework the first time that someone
requests the ibreakfast service
interface then create a new breakfast
service object but from now on
throughout the lifetime of the
application every time someone requests
this interface always use the same
breakfast service object that you just
created
another option over here is to say
scoped
scope says within the lifetime of a
single request the first time someone
requests this interface then create a
new object but from now until we finish
processing this request every time we
create an object and it requests this
interface then return the same breakfast
service object that you created before
okay there's also transient which as you
would expect basically says every time
someone requests this interface create a
new breakfast service object
okay now looking at our breakfast
service object
so because we're persisting our
breakfast inside this dictionary over
here we don't want this dictionary to be
recreated every request so let's change
this to static
okay and over here let's change this
back to scoped
great let's try running our application
again
and see if it works now
so we make the create breakfast request
as we can see we get here the http
status code 201 created
we get the location header and we get
the breakfast response which contains
the server generated id and less
modified date time
right let's take the id
of the breakfast that was just generated
and let's try retrieving it over here so
let's replace this id with the idea of
the breakfast and make the get request
and we can see that this works as we
expect so we get http status scoped 200
okay and over here again we have our
breakfast response okay now one thing
about the create breakfast so let's
create another breakfast
we said that the location header
contains a route which we can use to
retrieve the resource that we just
created so let's try and using this to
retrieve the breakfast so i'm copying it
and pasting it
back over here
now if you want to send multiple
requests from the same file then you can
do it by typing three hashtags and you
can see that now we can send another
request from the same file let's use
http get and make the request
and we can see that it works back in our
controller let's implement the methods
that are still missing let's also stop
our service
so let's implement the update endpoint
so over here let's create breakfast
given the details that we have
great so it's similar to the crate only
that we're using the id that we got from
the route
then we want to use the breakfast
service to observe the breakfast so yes
let's generate this method
and we want to return here no content
now if you remember then in this
endpoint we want to return no content
only if the id is an id of a breakfast
that exists in our database otherwise if
this is a brand new id and the details
here are valid then we want to create a
new dinner and we want to return here a
similar response as we're doing in the
create endpoint so let's add here a to
do
return 201 if a new breakfast
was created
right last but not least let's delete
the breakfast so
breakfast service dot
will eat breakfast and let's pass the id
let's generate this method
and return here
no content
and back in our services let's implement
the two missing methods so implement
interface
delete will be simply
remove the entry with the given id
and for upsert they'll simply be
breakfasts
and add it to the dictionary
let's make sure that this works as we
expect so let's rerun the service
so create created a new breakfast
let's
copy the id
and paste it over here in the get
breakfast
let's try retrieving it and we retrieved
it successfully let's copy the id
to the after breakfast and over here
let's change this
let's make it i don't know
vegan sunshine too
let's make the request
you can see we got here no content which
means it was updated successfully
let's try retrieving the breakfast again
and we can see we got it with the
updated value
now let's copy the id and delete the
breakfast
and we get no content again which means
that it deleted it successfully so now
if we try to get the breakfast again
what do you think will happen
and an exception was thrown and we can
see over here the exception that
occurred so this is basically the
exception to string
here's the exception message
and here's our stack trace
can if we go back to the breakfast
service implementation okay we can see
that this happens because we're not
accessing the dictionary safely but
before we fix this we actually never
want to return to the client the
exceptions that were thrown it may
contain sensitive information and also
we don't want the client to see the
stack trace and what happened inside our
system and how it's implemented so let's
add global error handling which
basically means how we handle exceptions
that are thrown in our system so back in
the program cs
we're going to add a middleware as
following so use exception handler and
over here let's specify some route
so when i said that you can imagine the
request simply arrives to the controller
so basically what we have is a pipeline
that our request goes through and if you
aren't familiar with middleware then you
can imagine it like a sandwich of code
you can write code that runs before and
after the next piece of middleware where
somewhere down the road one of the
middlewares actually invokes the
controller what we did over here is
we're using a built-in capability of the
framework to add code that basically
adds a try catch surrounding the
following middlewares
and then if an exception is thrown then
it catches that exception it changes the
request route to the route that we
defined over here and it re-executes the
request
and what this means is that over here we
can create a new controller and we can
call it errors controller
so public class
here is controller yes let's just change
this to controller base let's say that
the route here is
error
and let's change this to problem
and let's explain what we have over here
so like we said it re-executes the
request to the error route then over
here we can have whatever error handling
logic that we want currently all we're
doing is using the problem method from
the controller base which will return
the http status code 500 internal server
error so i want us to run the program
and see what this looks like now
so let's rerun it and make the get
request again so we don't have anything
in the database so this should throw an
exception and we can see that we no
longer get the exception as it was
thrown but we get this next response
with 500 internal server error
and no sensitive information will return
to our client
okay so this brings us to the next part
of our video which is error handling so
there are many approaches for handling
the error flow in our system
what we're going to do today is use an
approach from functional programming
where basically what we'll do we'll say
when you request a breakfast we'll
either return the breakfast like you
requested but if for some reason we
can't do it for example the breakfast
doesn't exist then we'll return an area
that represents what happened okay so
let's see what this looks like
so first of all i want to add a new
package to our application so dotnet add
to
the boober
breakfast project
the package okay now this package is
called error or it's my personal
favorite for handling this approach
you know if you know me and you know
this package then you know i'm not very
objective and that's because well i
wrote this package but
it really gives you some functionality
that doesn't exist in other packages so
let's get familiar with it
i actually made a video about the two
main approaches for flow control so if
you're curious to see exceptions for
flow control against this kind of
approach then make sure to check it out
we look at multiple open source
libraries and you can see what's right
for your application okay so inside the
blue breakfast folder let's create a new
folder it's called service errors
and over here let's create a new file
let's call it
errors.breakfast
dot cs
and what we'll have over here is a
public static class
errors and inside here a public style
class
breakfast
and in here we'll define all the areas
that we expect to have in our system
that are related to the breakfast
resource
now over here an era that we're
expecting to have is a breakfast that
doesn't exist so let's go ahead and
represent that error
so public static
error
not found
now if we look at this error object then
we can see it comes from that error or
package
and what this is so it's a simple struct
which has inside three things it has a
code which is unique to the error that
occurred
it has a description which is a human
readable description of what happened
and it has an error type
what is this error type it's a simple
enum which has inside failure which is
the default value and some other errors
which are common in any system right so
in our case we have something that
wasn't found so let's go ahead and use
this one
so the way this works you can do error
dot and over here you can use each one
of these methods to create the
corresponding error object plus you can
also use some custom integer value if
you prefer
so in our case we want not sound
and what you give it over here is the
unique code so for example
breakfast
dot not found right so this is the code
for the description
let's say
yeah something like this
then back in our breakfast service this
returns either an error or the breakfast
okay now this arrow or object comes from
the error or namespace yeah let's update
our implementation as well and see how
we'll use it so error or
breakfast
let's include the namespace
and what we can simply do now
try to retrieve the breakfast so try get
value that corresponds to the id
inside
this variable
if this succeeded then simply return the
breakfast
otherwise we want to return an error in
our case yes exactly this let's just
include the namespace
and if you're asking yourself how these
two become this arrow or object then
inside the arrow or object you can see
we have two implicit converters one that
gets the value in our case the breakfast
and converts it to an error or object
and the other one gets an error and
converts it to the error or object okay
so that's how it works behind the scenes
then back in our controller
then when
we're getting the breakfast this no
longer returns breakfast but it returns
an error
or the breakfast
right this is no longer a breakfast but
it's the get breakfast result
okay now this may contain the breakfast
but it also may contain the error so
over here we want to branch out
depending on what we have so we can say
if the get breakfast result
is an error
and
yes similar to this let's accept it and
understand why this doesn't work so back
in the error or object this actually
contains either the value or a list of
errors so you're not limited to store
only one error so back over here
we can access it using the first error
property
then if the first error is not found
then we want to return not found
wise we know we have the breakfast in
our hand so we can say breakfast
equals
yes the get breakfast result dot value
so this will simply return the breakfast
that we returned we can map it to the
response and return it same as we did
before so let's run this and make sure
that it works
okay so we're making a get request and
since we don't have any object then we
get not found
as we want but if we first create it and
we take
the id and use it to retrieve then we
see we get the response as we expect
okay so back in the breakfast controller
you may be looking at the method that we
implemented and you're thinking to
yourself that this is a much less
readable than what we had before after
all we can simply throw an exception
from the breakfast service
and catch it over here in the airs
controller and then our controller can
stay like it was before so you are right
let's see how we can make this a bit
more concise first of all let's extract
this mapping logic to a method so
extract method
and let's give it the name
map
breakfast response
and i want us to get familiar with the
following capability of the error or
object so for now let me comment out
all these lines
and see how we can use the match method
so what we're able to do is say return
get breakfast result dot match
so as you can see the match method
receives two functions one that will run
if what we have is the value in our case
the breakfast and another one that will
run if what we have is an error so let's
see how we can use it
let's define the first function
we have a breakfast if we got the
breakfast then we simply want to map it
using the method that we just defined so
map breakfast response and that's it the
breakfast
and if we have an error so this is the
list of errors what we can do is handle
it over here for now let's just return
here a problem
and see how this behaves
so let's run the application again
and we try to make the get breakfast
request then we can see that it
correctly invoked
the problem method
okay so i want to go back to the
breakfast controller so currently we're
checking if the first error is
specifically one of the service errors
but actually what we can do is we can
take the type of the error and according
to the type return the appropriate
response to the client so if you
remember back over here the type of
error error is not found so we don't
need to do something that's very
specific for this error but rather we
can do something that's a bit more
general so for that what we'll do i'll
delete all the logic over here
and i want us to implement our own
problem method so for that i'm going to
go over here and create here a new
controller which will be the base
controller of the other controllers
that's called api controller
so over here we'll have a public class
api controller which yes we'll inherit
from the controller base
and as we said this will be the base
controller for the other controllers so
let's go ahead and start inheriting from
the controller base over here instead
let's inherit from the api controller
and because these are attributes which
we can expect on any one of our
controllers let's move them to our base
controller
and over here like we said we'll have
our own problem implementation which
will receive a list of errors and return
the appropriate response so the way this
will look is protected by action
problem which will receive the list of
errors
and for now let's have your something
simple so let's say our first error
equals
the first error
yes and over here we can say that the
status quo depends on the type of the
first error
so we can say
type
which
and over here
yes something like this so we can say if
it's not found then
status codes dot not found if it's
validation
then we want
400
otherwise let's return here internal
server error and we also have here
conflict so let's go ahead and use that
as well so conflict will be
conflict exactly
and over here let's return a problem
where the status code is the status code
and the title
is the description of the first error
right
as so let me just close the terminal
okay so all we have at the moment is our
own base controller implementation which
the other controllers will inherit from
and what we'll do from now on is in the
controllers when we end up with a list
of errors then we'll call our own
problem method which currently all we're
doing is taking the first error using
the type to compute the correct status
code and then we're using the problem
method from the controller base to
return the status code and the
description of the first error okay so
now that we have this defined
back in the get breakfast method then
what we can do over here is pass the
list of errors
to the problem method so now this
problem method is the one that we
implemented in our base controller and
that's it let's make sure that this
works so start the program run it again
and now when we try to do it for your
breakfast that doesn't exist then we can
see we get here
the description of the first error and
we successfully converted the error type
to the correct http status code
great so back in the controller again
all we're doing is calling the breakfast
service receiving an error or the
breakfast if it's the breakfast then
we're mapping it to the correct response
and returning it to the client otherwise
we're using here our custom problem
method which converts the list of errors
to the appropriate response great let's
go ahead and do the same for the rest of
the methods in the breakfast service all
right so this will be error or
created this created also comes from the
arrow or library for the observed let's
say here or updated
and for the delete let's say air or
deleted
then back in the implementation
let's update this so this is error or
rated this simply returns
result.created
again this comes from the arrow or
library in the delete
then it's air or
deleted
and let's copy this
paste it in the delete method and change
this
to delete it
and lastly we have the observed
so we have this here or
updated
and we can return here
result dot updated
okay now one of the reasons that i
really like this approach is because as
the application grows and we have more
and more errors then all the errors are
neatly organized over here
and over here in each method it's very
clear to see what happens in the good
flow and what happens in the bad flow
here let's update the controller as well
so over here we get
the
create
breakfast result
which is
error or created
first of all we can get rid of this
entire thing
instead use the map method that we
created right so this will be breakfast
and then for now we can say if great
breakfast result is error
then we want to return
problem and pass the errors to the base
controller
otherwise we want to return the same
response
and then let's just move this to the
bottom so it's more organized
then let's start with the delete so this
returns the
delete
result which is error or deleted
then over here we can say
yes actually
right so if it deleted then we want to
return no content otherwise if there's
an error then we want to return the
appropriate response
and lastly the upsert so over here if
you remember we want to return 201 if a
new breakfast was created
okay so it would be nice if the upper
breakfast method could somehow tell us
if it created a new breakfast or not so
to do this what we can do actually is go
over here
and instead of returning error or
updated which comes from the arrow or
package we can create our own response
model let's say something like abserted
breakfast result
and this could be whatever we want so
for example public record struct
upstarted breakfast
and here we can have whatever extra
details that we want so for example
is
newly created
which will indicate if we created a new
breakfast or not
and then over here we can say
bar is newly created
equals yes right so if the breakfast
dictionary doesn't contain the given id
then we're creating a new one
then what we still have left to do
is update the method definition
so this will be absurd breakfast both
here
and here
then
we can return here
a new upstarted breakfast
and pass it the is newly created value
then back in the controller
this returns the absurd result
and over here we want to return 201 if a
new breakfast was created
so because we have the same thing over
here let's extract this twee method
let's call it something like created at
get breakfast
let's fix the indentation
and move it to the bottom
okay back in the offset method what we
can do now
is basically
absolute result dot match
yes almost
so if it upset it then what we want to
do is check if it was newly created
if yes we want to return
created at let's fix the typo
get breakfast
otherwise we want to turn
no content lastly let's just align the
variable names so this is observed
breakfast result and over here
it's
delete breakfast result
okay so that seems about right we can
actually make the create breakfast a bit
more concise so we can replace this
entire thing
with
create breakfast results
and we can match
on the result
and say if it was created
then
we can return the created at get
breakfast and pass it the breakfast
otherwise we can use the problem method
and pass it the errors
okay so just to recap
all the errors that we expect in our
system sit over here and we have them
well defined with a unique error code
and a descriptive description
then in our i breakfast service then we
define for each one of the methods that
they can either return the expected
result or an error now because we aren't
really expecting any error in some of
these methods then we could have simply
replaced it with void but i just wanted
to demonstrate another capability that
might be relevant in your application
then lastly in our controller then we
get the response
and we return the appropriate response
to the client
based on whatever result we received
great let's run the project and make
sure that everything still works as we
expect
so we create a new dinner
we get here the response that we expect
let's take the id
and use it
to retrieve it
great this also works as we expect
let's try updating it
so we get no content which is good it
means a new resource wasn't created
let's try deleting the breakfast and we
get no content again which means that it
was deleted successfully so now when we
try to get it again then we get 404 not
found
and if we do upsert then because it
doesn't exist we expect it to create a
new dinner so let's try
and we see we didn't get no content but
rather we got 201 created
with a new resource and the given id
that we specified
great let's make sure that this was
stored in the database so let's try to
retrieve it and we can see that it was
stored in our in-memory database as we
expect
now let's move on to the final part of
this video which is enforcing our
business rules on our internal service
models so if you remember over here when
we create the breakfast then there are
some rules that we might want to enforce
on the data that we're receiving so at
the moment the client can call us with
whatever information they want and we'll
simply store it and also the controller
can put whatever value they want over
here in the last modified date time and
will simply store it as is it would be
nice if we can simply take the data and
say okay here's breakfast if everything
was valid and it adheres to the rules
that the business defines
otherwise here's a list of well-defined
errors
okay so let's see how we can do that so
over here let's create a static factory
method and this will look as following
so public static this will turn an error
or a breakfast
and let's call this create
let's just include the arrow or
namespace
okay the way this will work is that
we'll change the constructor to private
but we're the only ones that can call it
over here we'll receive the various
details so
yes this seems right let's just inline
this
and now instead of enforcing our logic
over here we can go ahead and enforce it
over here
so the way this could look
so let's say for example the name needs
to be between 3 and 50 characters and
the description needs to be between 50
and 150 characters okay now i'm giving
this as an example but something you
might actually want to do is make sure
that the start and end time are actually
values that make sense for a breakfast
and the start date time is in the future
okay so let's look at how something like
this can be implemented so for example
public
constant min
name length
now let's have a three
and let's have
the max name length
we said 50
and let's have the same thing
for the description so let's change name
to description
let's change three
to 50
and
the maximum
to 150.
then over here on the create method then
we can say okay if the length
of the name
is less than
the
minimum length
or greater than
the maximum length then over here we can
return an error that represents that the
name isn't valid
so for example let me just close
everything so it's more organized
we can go to our service errors to the
breakfast
and create here
some
validation error
let's call it
invalid name
dot
invalid name
and over here we can say that the
breakfast name
must be at least
yes it seems
right
let's just update this too
models not breakfast
dot min name length
both over here
and over here
and
let's wrap the line
great then over here we can simply
return
errors
dot breakfast dot
invalid name
and we can have similar logic for that
description
so let's change
name to
description and here as well
and let's add the appropriate
error over here
and
here let's change
everything to description as well and
this should be also description
and now this should work great and we
can actually make this a bit better if
you remember we said that internally we
have here a list of errors so we don't
actually have to return only one of
these errors we can actually return all
of them so what we can do we can create
here
a list of errors
and over here
simply edit
like so
and same thing over here so errors dot
add
and add the appropriate error
and in the end we can yes if there are
any errors
then let's simply return
the list of errors
okay so similar to the other implicit
converters there's also an implicit
converter that takes a list of errors
and returns an error or object
okay back in the controller
breakfast dot create
and we no longer need to pass it this
and this since it's generated inside
we can call this request to breakfast
result
which is either the error or breakfast
then we can say
if this thing is an error then
we want to return
a problem
otherwise we know we have a breakfast in
our hand and we can simply extract the
breakfast from the arrow or object and
use it like we did before
okay same thing over here in the upsort
so here we would have breakfast
dot create
we would remove this
but we do want the option to pass the id
so let's create here an optional field
with id
and back over here let's just move the
id
to the end
and same over here so this will be
request to breakfast result
and over here we can say
if it's an error then return
the errors
otherwise let's take the breakfast and
we continue like we did before
then over here in the create method
let's generate a new id only if an id
wasn't specified
and that's it for now so just to recap
what we have
we changed the constructor to be private
so no one can create a breakfast other
than using the create static factory
method
then over here we can enforce whatever
business rules that we have that have to
do with the breakfast object okay so
we're encapsulating logic that has to do
with a breakfast inside the breakfast
object
finally we're turning either the
breakfast or a list of errors to the
controller
which it's the controller's
responsibility to make sure that what he
has
is a valid value
now back over here
we would simply return the first error
and that's a shame because we know we
have here a list of errors with details
that are very relevant to the client to
know how to fix his request so instead
let's check if everything that we have
in this list of errors are validation
errors so we can say if
errors
that all
and
the type of all of them is
validation
then what we want to do is we return a
validation problem so the controller
base has another method which is called
validation problem
which if we give it a model state
dictionary we'll convert it to a
beautiful error response which contains
all the details so let's see what this
looks like so we want to create here a
model state dictionary
and to this model state dictionary we
want to add all the errors that occurred
so the way we can do this
is
yes exactly
right so we're simply iterating through
the errors and adding a dictionary entry
with the error code and the description
and then we need to pass it to the
validation problem method
as so
and that's it right so we're basically
saying if all we have
are validation problems then let's
return
bad requests with all the details
and this will return a standard response
otherwise let's take the first error and
return
the appropriate response
you know we can actually make it a bit
better so let's imagine that five errors
occurred
if even one of them is an unexpected
error then we can't really trust any of
the other errors so we can add
some logic that says
if
there's any error
where
the error type
is
unexpected
then we want to return
500 internal server error okay let's run
our project and make sure that it
behaves as we expect
let's first look at the good flow so
creating a new breakfast works as we
expect
let's try retrieving it
works as we expect as well let's try
updating something
we get no content so let's try
retrieving it again
we can see that we got the updated value
lastly let's try deleting it
and we get no content so when we try
getting it now then great we get not
found if we try to upset it
then we can see
it was created as we expect
now i want us to test the error flow
let's put here some details that are
invalid
and try to make the request
and we can see we got
bed requests
with descriptive errors of what happened
let's just fix
the space that we're missing so back in
the errors
let's add a space both here
and here you know back in our breakfast
controller we can actually add another
static factory method
which knows how to take the
request and return the same result so
let's see what something like this would
look like
so back in the breakfast object
similar to the create gonna have here a
public static
error or
breakfast
which receives
the
create breakfast requests
and simply calls the create method
like we did in the controller
and we can do the same thing in the
observe method as well so over here
let's do from
let's replace this entire thing with the
id
and the request
and let's add here another static
factory method
which knows how to take
the id
and the officer breakfast request
and similarly
you'll call it with the details and the
id
and will return
an error or the breakfast right we can
remove this comment
you know if you're looking at this over
here and you're thinking
this is much less readable than what we
had in the beginning and if we simply
threw exceptions both for the breakfast
object and for the breakfast service
then you are right we are paying here a
price of readability but i want you to
remember that as the application grows
over here we currently have one
controller and one service but as the
application grows we'll probably end up
having many services many controllers
and more logic down the road and
throwing exceptions makes it hard to
understand what the error flows in your
application are and what errors can
occur so personally even though this
approach can take a few minutes to get
used to
what you gain is that you have your
errors well-defined
and as you're developing the application
you're mindful of the scenarios that
might occur okay so that's it for this
video i really hope you had a good time
and you have a better understanding of
how to build a crud based rest api
completely from scratch i cover topics
that are a bit more advanced in my
channel so if this wasn't freeing and
you enjoyed it make sure to check it out
and i'll see you in the next one